[Música]
obrigado a todos uma boa tarde ou pedir
desculpas mas eu vou usar uma colinha é
a dica que eu não sou um palestrante
profissional como todos os outros
subiram no palco mas eu prometo que vou
dar o meu melhor né objetivo nessa
palestra transformando faixas pretas
dentro e fora do tatame
eu não tô aqui é exatamente para
palestrar o meu objetivo principal aqui
é contar histórias destrói se
transformaram vidas e podem transformar
a vida dos pequenos detalhes fazem
grande diferença
nada mais justo pra começar com uma
história é contando a sua história
quando tinha quatro anos eu era um
menino muito hiperativo no banheiro e
uma amiga da minha mãe contou que o
jogador
ajudava a queima energia e que vai ficar
mais sossegado em casa começou o jogo
com quatro anos foi amor à primeira
vista
foi uma coisa maravilhosa realmente ia
me identifiquei com o jogador
fiquei um garoto mais obediente e mais
focado em tudo principalmente na escola
sempre fui um bom aluno e aos 13 anos eu
sair de palhano e foi morar na barra ea
minha grande angústia era onde eu vou
treinar judô
foi aí que eu tive a felicidade de
chegar aos 45 academista na barra da
tijuca e não tinha gostado de nenhuma e
acho que na quarta e na quinta eu
encontrei o geraldo bernardes que já era
é do comitê olímpico brasileiro de judô
já tinha ganhado junto com aurélio
miguel medalha era uma pessoa que o foco
é olímpico era treinamento de alto
rendimento e lá com 13 anos começou o
sonho olímpico o objetivo real e de
todos que estavam ali era realmente se
tornar o faixa preta e trazer uma
medalha para o brasil
tudo começa com o planejamento um
planejamento uma criança de 13 anos era
o que é bom eu tiro nota alta
meu pai não me tira do
eu tinha nota baixo sai do jogador então
meu planejamento único exclusivo era ser
um bom aluno
se eu for um bom aluno papai bonzinho
paga a mensalidade
os campeonatos começaram a crescer e nós
fomos evoluindo é as crianças foram
começando a ter mais responsabilidades
os treinamentos foram ficando mais
intensos nós já estamos com 15 16 17
anos a diferença de idade
na turma era mais ou menos dois a três
anos era uma equipe muito focado
a era uma aprendiz na barra da tijuca
para quem conhece e é na verdade um pólo
de uma universidade que dava à bolsa de
estudo para alunos que se destacasse no
esporte e todos que estavam no mar
pedido fosse estudado na universidade
com certeza teriam bolsas porque
realmente era um atleta de alto
rendimento
os treinamentos foram ficando mais forte
as dores aumentando as contusões e isso
fez com que começasse a diferenciar quem
tinha determinação para continuar e
buscar o seu sonho e quem apenas tinha
vontade de propina
então tinha uma galera aqui a treinar na
nova forte mas chegava no final de
semana e é pra pra matinê né eu ia pra
noitada feche americana
o pessoal que fazer mais alto rendimento
realmente não deixava de fazer certas é
esportes até a gente e evitava até de
jogar futebol porque machucado muito
engraçado em pokhara o piloto ajudou o
primeiro jogar futebol é a cara à luta
judô tem medo de jogar futebol que o
macho o futebol realmente machuca
então essa determinação começou a
diferenciar as equipes
nossa equipe tinha o flávio canto
então nas olimpíadas de 2000 e 96 foi
atlanta
a seletiva foi 95 eu tinha apenas 17
anos
o pedro o irmão flávio também 17 e o
flávio é o mais velho da nossa equipe
ele tinha 19 anos
e todos nós entramos na seletiva já
sabendo que o cara não temos chance o
judô você começa a criar maturidade
acima dos 20 anos
então vamos lá pra ver avanços casca
grossa e começar a ganhar é é a
experiência com o computador e os mais
velhos e aí para nossa felicidade o
flávio ganhou a seletiva foi para a
olimpíada e ficou em sétimo teve um
resultado espetacular ele tinha 20 anos
quando participou da olimpíada e isso
fez com que o marapendi a que botou
flávio para o mundo flávio começou a ser
conhecido no mundo
os treinamentos fosse ficassem muito
mais intenso então vinha pessoal do juiz
que ajudou muito flávio é
reconhecidamente um cara ótimo no chão
por causa do intercâmbio com juros
os treinos começaram a ficar muito mais
forte e as conquistas começaram a
aparecer não só do flávio mas de toda a
equipe que estava no entorno dele
o flamengo sempre fala e obviamente os
pastores judoca vai falar o uso do toque
ele não ganha sozinho ele pode entrar no
tatame sozinho mas se não tiver um
sparring de alto nível
união 345 ele não vai conseguir evoluir
e chegar no nível que ele precisa para
ser campeão e foi aí que meu sonho e
sofreu o primeiro baque é eu tinha 19
anos e ia treinando nessa universidade
que tinha bolsa sofreu uma queda algo
completamente normal só que como estava
treinando muitas pessoas
acabei batendo em alguém antes de cair
no chão e rompi o ligamento do ouro uma
fraca 1 chegou a ser fratura foi só
ligamentar
porém eu tive que ficar seis meses sem
treinar em alto rendimento três meses em
recuperação depois mais três meses de
fisioterapia
isso foi algo muito difícil na minha
vida é um momento que eu estava melhor
de todos
mas graças à equipe que eu tinha eu
voltei a treinar mais forte ainda
comecei a ter melhores resultados ainda
pensando nas olimpíadas de 2000 e cisne
porém aconteceu o segundo baque
eu fui pro campeonato em são paulo que é
o campeonato mais difícil que já tinha
disputado foi campeão do campeonato
porém resolvi a para me testar mais
ainda lutar o absoluto absoluta uma
categoria de peso e na final estava
lutando com um rapaz que uma pilha da
big mac e eu fui fazer uma posição no
chão meu pé ficou preso no quimono dele
ele veio pra cima de mim e eu rompi a
todos os ligamentos do joelho e isso foi
é o momento de uma escolha
eu tinha que decidir esperar 2004 mas
cinco anos
já a terceira olimpíada tentando e acho
que nem todos sabem mas só vai o o por
categoria no brasil
ou continuar lutando judô por hobby e
decidir virar um empresário que é o que
eu sou até hoje constitui uma empresa 98
foi a melhor escolha que eu tive
continua até hoje muito ativo o judô ou
não como um atleta mas como um formador
de atletas e isso me traz muita
satisfação
cada vez que eu vejo é essa escolha é
minha do passado
eu acho que foi assertiva às vezes a
gente tem que cair a levantar capital é
entre 96 e 2000 lopes o fla começou a
ficar conhecido o nós na noite de natal
os amigos ali é nos 9 e 10
a gente pegar os carros ia passear na
zona sul ipanema leblon e ipanema dando
comida que sobrava da ceia de natal
aquilo ali era mágico a gente achava
maravilhoso a gente
tentava conversava com o as pessoas que
moravam os moradores de rua
contato dava aquela atenção que eles
precisavam e o mais incrível é que
aquele sentimento maravilhoso no dia
seguinte é igualzinho uma ressaca porque
você de comida por um rapaz de uma
atenção hoje em dia de 365 dias e aquilo
ali no terceiro ano a gente já viu que
não era aquilo que a gente queria fazer
o flávio no cara sempre diferenciado
sempre pensando no terceiro setor
ele chamou todos os amigos pra casa dele
me lembro como se fosse hoje
nós vamos 9 e ele chegou e falou assim
galera eu quero fazer alguma coisa que a
gente diminua a distância das classes
sociais
bom todo mundo olhou para a cara do
outro o porte bonitos lá como é que a
gente faz isso
ele falou bruno ou não lembro quem eu o
documento faz isso mas falou assim
quando a gente entra no tatame
não importa se o cara da cidade de deus
se o cara dá assim o cara estudam na
escola americano ali dentro do tatame
nós somos todos de baixo porque a gente
não faz uma onde de judô e foi unânime
beleza vão fazer mas não fazer como nem
a gente não tem dinheiro mas todos nós
na época eu já estava trabalhando deve
ter os 19 anos isso e aí nós nos
comprometemos cada um com dalin dar uma
quantia que era pequena mas pra gente na
época era algo relevante mensal para a
gente conseguir pagar professores para
dar aula na comunidade
acabou que a coisa foi crescendo foi
aumentando eu dava aula inclusive aos
sábados como um voluntário valverde
também entre outras pessoas ea gente
soube de um outro do geraldo bernardes
que o nosso sensei um grande formador
dos atletas e de pessoas
ele tinha também um projeto na cidade de
deus e que um outro projeto do pai do
dono na pequena cruzada unirmos forças e
constituímos na verdade primeiro uma
onde ainda não era
tudo reação mas já era uma transformação
na rocinha pequena cruzada e e cidade de
deus que em 2003
a gente conseguiu realmente constitui a
onde o flávio no meio de treino pra a
competir em 2004 e graças a muito treino
e muito foco o flávio foi o 3º lugar nas
olimpíadas de atenas conseguiu dar mais
visibilidade ao instituto o instituto
hoje nem eu sei até que ponto os povos
temas acho que são nove são mais 1.600
crianças são mais de 8 mil pessoas
impactadas por que você impacto não só a
criança mas o seu impacto na família da
criança
é a reação ele passa a ser a segunda
casa dessas crianças
ele não é só ajudou ele tem reforço
escolar ele tem alto rendimento ele tem
dentro do olímpico ele tem é é a
patrocinadores para pagar às escolas das
crianças
então é muito mais do que apenas o
enxuto de judô
é os valores do judô eu carrego com eles
na minha vida
levei ele para a empresa eu acho que são
fundamentais para o crescimento é e tem
uma frase o papel uma colinha aqui a que
a gente fala né eles podem muito mais do
que pensam que podem
isso é muito importante para as crianças
entenderem que o céu não é o limite
podem chegar aonde quiserem e tem uma
frase também que é bom você refletir em
levar uma fase curtinha dodô fernando
pessoa que fala o homem é do tamanho do
seu sonho
então acho que essa frase vale a
reflexão e as transformações não foi o
que eu falei é o reação ele passa a ser
a segunda causa dessas crianças e desses
jovens e as transformações transformando
faixa preta dentro e fora do tatame
eu falo muito e mostra essa essa imagem
essa imagem a nossa equipe de bateria
nem sei quantos anos eu tinha 14 15
eu era o menino do canto faixa verde
parece que preta mas a faixa verde
o flávio está ali também geraldo e e nós
temos um monte de faixas pretas aí que
não necessariamente irão faixas pretas
no tatame mas só hoje apresentador de tv
via a advogado dos maiores escritórios
tributaristas do brasil o publicitário
engenheiro e esse é o nicho o núcleo que
eu convidaria por isso que eu falo que o
faixa-preta de fora do tatame também e
agora contando um pouco da história e se
sorrisão aí na verdade dois horizontes
não sorrisão do feijão como é conhecido
o ele ele a corporação ele não era tão
novinho já era um jovem mas o sonho dele
era completar o segundo grau é o que ele
pensava mais alto e graças à reação ele
além de ter completado o segundo grau
ele fez faculdade hoje dá uma aula uma
série de locais
infelizmente não está aqui hoje ele foi
meu convidado para vir hoje aqui e isso
aqui tá dando aula não conseguiu nem
para render ele queria prestar uma
homenagem para ele aquele outro bonitão
o meu filho no primeiro campeonato dele
é o professor e ele não estava o feijão
nunca tinha visto o meu filho e meu
filho estava apavorado não queria entrar
direto no tatame o feijão veio perguntou
se podia falar com ele rapidamente falei
claro achando que e assim vão e eu
acredito muito em energia
eu acho que a energia que o feijão
recebeu no reason ele passou pro meu
filho e ele saiu carregando meu filho
meu filho sorrindo não entende nada e
entrou no tatame lutou eu falei meu deus
x 16 anos reação mas os trechos foram
antecipados acabaram de ser pagos aqui
nesse momento então pessoas incríveis
como ele como é mais conhecida de todos
com certeza conhece e rafaela silva é a
única brasileira até a tríplice coroa
ela foi campeã mundial júnior um campeão
mundial sênior em campanha campeã
olímpica foi a primeira medalha de ouro
olímpico no brasil quem controla o
geraldo bernardes era uma menina que que
tinha tudo pra ir por um caminho errado
uma menina revoltada que morava na
cidade de deus e na banheira e hoje é
uma formadora de opinião uma grande
atleta um exemplo por um monte de
crianças que treinam no reação e tem um
filme que adoram que é o pai falando pro
filho acredita todo mundo já tenha dito
esse filme mas tem uma situação que
aparece um monte de vídeos na internet é
na parte da procura da felicidade
eu tentei de quadro econômico e cobrar
mas eu prefiro falar porque se eu errar
vai ficar feia é um problema mais 40
anos ficou muito chega né
nunca deixe ninguém se dizer que não
pode fazer alguma coisa
nem mesmo eu está bem se você tem um
sonho tem que correr atrás dele e as
pessoas se as pessoas não conseguem
vencer e dizem que você também não vai
vencer
se você quer alguma coisa corra atrás
ponto isso acho que é uma frase que se
leva para a vida
coloquei essas bolinhas que a doação e
ração né e
então eu deixo um recado aqui pra todos
vocês que é o que eu falo sempre que eu
falo com a minha equipe da telecom que
hoje tem mais três países é tem três
países mas cem pessoas trabalhando que é
de em o melhor de você você pode mais do
que você imagina
e pra finalizar eu quero passar um
manifesto é o vídeo do reação é isso que
está na minha frente não é na adversária
não é contra ele que luta a luta é
contra as estatísticas que dizem que meu
futuro já está definido é contra essa
idéia que eu reagi é contra essa idéia
reagir contra essa idéia que eu reagi
porque porque essa faixa na minha
cintura de justamente o contrário
ela disse que eu possa ciência o que eu
quiser que eu consigo sim vencer
qualquer dificuldade
a minha guerra é luta meu amigo não é
dentro do tatame fora dele é fora dele
quero ver você quer me derrubar caiu
levanta rio de janeiro
eu vou reagir mas como fazer o que é a
rocinha
a gente vai reagir você vai fazer o quê
caso o rio de janeiro
sou forte vem reagiu comigo que a gente
sabia campo
reaja à cidade de deus é o vosso teodoro
viaja gamboa reaja brasil
raja brasil
[Música]
a rede target
vêm reagir com a gente
[Aplausos]